what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about one of the most iconic
MADD Chadd lads in recent anime history
the bore mask wearing ass-kicking dual
wielding tangelo annoying
eNOS Kakashi Mira eNOS kay is best known
for his hilarious outbursts that provide
a lot of humor to the demon slayer story
and at first you may be tempted to think
that along with being a strong fighter
in nose-kiss role in the story is little
more than comic relief but the beauty of
demon slayer is that the characters are
multi-dimensional and multifaceted this
includes virtually everyone from minor
demons to the main cast of the series
including of course our boy in Oscar as
the story progresses we learn more about
in escape including his tragic backstory
and we see him grow into a more complex
and nuanced character in this video I
will be taking a look at the character
we know scare as a whole and how he
overcame a tragic and difficult past in
order to become the hilarious badass
that we know today if you enjoyed this
video you want to see more demon slayer
content right here on the channel please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications if you don't make sure to
turn on all notifications YouTube will
bury a lot of our videos that's just the
way it goes you can also follow me on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest demon slayer news
including news about the new demon
slayer movie quick warning this video
will contain spoilers from the demon
slayer manga i am dealing with all the
available information that we have so
far about eNOS sky and his life so
please proceed with caution
you have been warned when I first saw
you no scare I thought that he was a
completely insane maniac who has
literally no common sense his actions
seemed totally wild and irrational yes
he was a brave and skilled fighter when
it came to taking on demons but he also
did many crazy things that put himself
and others in danger eNOS Kay is
obsessed with proving that he is the
strongest fighter and that he can defeat
anyone in a fight and in order to prove
this
he often engages in incredibly reckless
and dangerous activities
he immediately challenges every
potential rival to a fight as soon as he
meets them whether they are a demon or a
demon slayer and he doesn't actually
stop to assess how strong his rival
might be as any martial artist or pro
fighter will tell you challenging an
opponent you know nothing about is
extremely dangerous
but in noski doesn't think twice before
doing exactly that and if this wasn't
enough even after realizing that an
opponent is far stronger than him and
that he has no realistic chance of
winning
eNOS Kerr refuses to give up he
continues fighting even if that causes
immense damage to his body and puts him
in mortal danger absolutely refusing to
admit defeat even in the most dire
situations on one occasion GU was forced
to tie in Oscar up after his battle with
the father of the spider family because
even after being severely injured by the
demon he no scale was so impressed by
gear skilled that he insisted on
challenging you to a duel
right then and there GU was actually
forced to tiny Oscar up so that in Oscar
wouldn't aggravate his own injuries
further and potentially kill himself in
the process the often irrational wild
and reckless aspect of in Oscars
personality is the result of the fact
that as a child he was actually raised
by wild boars this makes it difficult
for an Oscar to understand social norms
and basic human interactions and
emotions especially at first which often
leads to hilarious misunderstandings and
very awkward situations initially
strength is the only thing that in Ostia
cares about he is always trying to test
his strength prove himself and triumph
over opponents his pride is so tied to
his own strength that any situation in
which he cannot win and prove himself to
be the strongest leads in Oscar to
become deeply sad and depressed
however as funny as some of these
situations that he knows he finds
himself in are in Oscar does continue to
grow as a character he slowly learns
more about human interaction and human
kindness and his friendship with tansy
Rose and Sue and other humans continues
to develop
he knows K even learns to respect the
strengths of other people in his
fighting style becomes more strategic
and logical rather than just a mad
his opponents with both swords swinging
wildly but the moment in the manga that
really allows us to understand the full
depth of in Oscars character is his
tragic backstory found in chapter 160
which explains how exactly he ended up
alone in the mountains as a baby and why
he found himself in a situation where he
had to be raised by wild boars when he
was just a baby
he knows cos mother who was only 17 or
18 at the time ran away from home
because her husband beat her and abused
her constantly back into early 1900s and
especially in a small town rural area
it's highly likely that woman had very
few options and protections when it came
to dealing with domestic abuse and
running away from one's husband under
any circumstances would have been
heavily frowned upon
however he knows cos mom still chose to
take that step in order to protect
herself and her baby which is an
incredibly brave act
he knows cos mom sought refuge with an
organization called eternal paradise an
organization that accepted people like
her since she had very few options and
since almost no one would have been
willing to help a wife fleeing her
husband back at that time he knows cos
mom sought refuge with eternal paradise
and its leader DOMA when she first came
to DOMA her face was beaten badly and
she had been blinded in one eye as a
result of all the abuse that she
suffered at the hands of her cruel
husband he knows his mother used to
always sing to baby noski but instead of
singing common lullabies she always sang
to him about pinky promises more
specifically she sang about her promise
to protect him until he became big
enough to protect himself she vowed to
protect him because he did not have his
father in his life any longer
and she pledged to do anything to
protect her son even at the cost of her
own life the leader of the organization
called
eternal paradise DOMA actually really
liked in Oscars mother and he enjoyed
having her around however it turns out
that eternal paradise was a cult created
by DOMA
and DOMA himself was a demon who used
the cult to lure in followers followers
whom he would later proceed to devour
he knows his mother eventually realized
what was happening and she curse
the DOMA for being such a monster and a
liar she then tried to escape the temple
of eternal paradise she could not be
part of something as horrifying and
sickening as a demon's cult as she runs
through the woods with little anushka in
her arms
he knows his mom apologizes to her son
for always going somewhere bad for
repeatedly allowing herself to be
manipulated by cruel abusers as she runs
from the demon DOMA he knows cos mom
arrives at a dead end a sharp cliff with
water beneath it as DOMA catches up to
her in Oscars mom decides to at least
give an Oscar a chance to live by
lowering him down below the cliff and
into the water just as DOMA arrives and
slashes her to death
he knows his mother didn't want both of
them to be killed by the demon and she
did her best to at least given Oscar a
fighting chance no matter how low his
chances of survival actually were DOMA
did not think that the child could
possibly survive the fall from the cliff
so he didn't bother looking for the
child any further DOMA simply satisfied
himself by devouring every part of in
Oscars mother but in no Skate did
survive he was found and taken in by
some wild boars and eventually he was
also noticed by some humans who lived in
the area and they helped him as well for
most of his life in Oscar has no idea
who his parents were or where he came
from
he lived in blissful ignorance unaware
of the tragedy that led to him becoming
who he is today it is only once he faces
the demon DOMA in the flesh that he
learns from Domas own mouth the cruel
fate of his mother and how he came to be
raised by wild boars in the first place
he knows Kia wasn't just someone who was
abandoned by his mother or someone who
was an orphan who somehow ended up in
the wilderness
instead he knows his mother was a really
kind and caring person
who was unfortunately faced with tragedy
after tragedy in her short life she
didn't want to give an auskey away to
the contrary she cared about him deeply
he meant everything to her and she
wanted to do everything in her power to
protect him but bad luck and evil people
kept following her and in the end she
was tragically killed and devoured by a
sociopathic demon so in the end Anastas
mother failed to protect him until he
became bigger and stronger and in that
sense she
broke her promise that she made to him
but at the same time she did manage to
save his life and prevent him from being
eaten by the demon and he did manage to
survive albeit due to a heavy dose of
good luck all of this has a massive
impact on in Oscar and on his character
once he learns all of this information
from the demon himself back when he
didn't know anything about his parents
or where he came from an Oscar saw
himself as different from normal humans
he grew up in the wilderness he grew up
with wild beasts and he wasn't really in
touch with his human side he didn't feel
compelled to bow to social norms and
expectations and he didn't see himself
as a full-fledged member of human
society but when he learns the truth
about his mother from the demon who
killed her
he knows kay is forced to come to terms
with his own humanity he was brought
into this world by a human and he
survived the demons attack because a
human his mother sacrificed her life to
save him
to quote Daft Punk this realization
forces in osku to accept that he is
human after all
and it also forces him to truly
understand how evil and cruel the demons
are he knows he can no longer think of
himself as a boy from the wilderness
with no past he is forced to come to
terms with his own tragic past and this
makes him a more rooted more complex and
more human character I love you know see
as a character for many reasons he is a
badass mad lad he is hilarious he has a
great character design and it has been a
joy to watch him develop as a character
and develop his relationship with other
humans Anushka cannot escape the fact
that he was raised by wild boars and
that this makes him different from other
humans to some extent he will always be
an outcast within the so-called
civilized society but at the same time
his tragic backstory reminds in no skid
that even though he is different he is
still human
he still has a past he still has a
family and he cannot escape from his
humanity no more than he can escape from
his unusual upbringing this duality of
Anastas character a human who was raised
outside of human society and yet is
still firmly connected to that same
society is what makes him such a
fascinating character and as he learns
to come to terms with his own past and
identity and with his role in humans
including his relationships with other
characters enos continues to grow and
develop into an exceptional anime and
manga character I can't wait to see how
an Oscar continues to grow as the story
progresses and I'm really looking
forward to seeing the evolution of the
relationships and friendships that he
has formed with other humans like
Tangier and Zenit Zoo he knows his life
has been difficult and tragic in many
ways but his unyielding fighting spirit
keeps pushing him forward and allows him
to triumph over hardship and adversity
to me this is truly inspirational and it
is one of the reasons why Innes K is one
of the most memorable anime characters
in recent memory let me know what you
guys think do you like you know C as a
character and where do you think his
character development will go from here
feel free to share your thoughts down in
the comments below if you enjoyed this
video you want to see more demon Surtur
content right here on the channel please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications if you don't make sure to
turn on all notifications you will
definitely miss a lot of our videos
that's just how YouTube works also
please feel free to hit me up on Twitter
and Instagram at anime uproar for all
the latest demon slayer news and updates
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons who support us
and make videos like this one possible
special thanks to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh baby Rey nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson Kings ell dress fitted ala
beat Anatole Cassatt Sookie DJ Nathaniel
and alpha do and I can't forget are the
one tier patrons the ones who stand
above all other clans including Ingrid
ah a Lola madam Maddie Mac makoto-kun
and the world and you know he's serious
because he didn't say so Waldo if you
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value to your life please
consider becoming a patron even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people as always thank you
guys so much for watching and until next
time see us bass cowboys
[Music]